I do coffee animals every other day. After it's done, I feel tiredness coming to my legs for a few hours that it goes away.
I do take minerals and make sure I'm not dehydrated.
What is the reason for the tiredness?
I would doubt that it's anything to do with dehydration.
Coffee animals really are drawing a lot of water from your body to your colon.
That's not really what they do.
So I would doubt that it was that and I certainly would, you know, say physiological basis highly doubt that there's any demonization of your tissues due to the coffee animal.
There's just no evidence of that anywhere.
So the achitis, tiredness in your legs could very well be neurological when you do a coffee animal and you're putting the tube up your rectum stimulates, of course, the neurological pathways back to the lumbar and sacred plexus.
Which could cause, you know, reflex fatigue and your muscles that are coming out and integrated through that same plexus will give you neurological more likely than that.
It's a parasympathetic stimulus.
So understand your purpose of doing a coffee animal is to stimulate the parasympathetics.
Well, what does the parasympathetic nervous system do?
Well, a parasympathetic nervous system stimulates the immune response.
Yeah, that's a win.
Parasympathetic nervous system stimulates a detoxification response because, well, neurologically, your detoxification pathways are controlled by your parasympathetics.
Parasympathetics are also call me response.
Everything that your sympathetic do and the parasympathetics do the opposite.
So what do the sympathetic do?
Your sympathetic are your fight, flight or freeze mechanism, polar bear jumps down in front of you.
Your blood pressure goes sky high to shunt blood to the extremities so that you can run away with a polar bear or fight.
And you go into full fight mode and you're trying to survive, you're in survival mode.
When you parasympathetics are call me your relaxing decrease anxiety.
They decrease your blood pressure.
They decrease the shunt blood to your extremities.
That's what you want to get that will help you relax and help you go to sleep.
So really your response is probably more parasympathetic response, which is actually good.
It's tiredness you feel in your legs.
That's why we suggest doing the coffee enemas in the evening so that you can just go to bed afterwards if you have to.
The only negative about that is people that are highly sensitive to caffeine.
The caffeine could keep them awake.
But most people tolerate that pretty well.
They're not absorbing a ton of the caffeine, especially if you're not dehydrated.
And you don't have the issue with that.